témoin du jour on va revenir sur la
disparition très mystérieuse de Lina une
jeune fille de 15 ans plus personne n'a
de nouvelle d'elle depuis samedi
après-midi lorsqu'elle tite son domicile
situé dans le Barin pour se rendre à la
gare à 2 km de chez elle alors
l'inquiétude est grande puisque selon
les déclarations de ses proches Lina
n'avait aucun souci avec sa famille et
ses amis ce n'était pas une jeune fille
qui pouvait potentiellement fuguer des
battues ont eu lieu pour tenter de la
retrouver dans un instant on aura Zoé
une collègue de Lina qui est peut-être
la dernière personne à l'avoir vu et
Michel Marie qui vont nous raconter
cette histoire folle mais juste avant
regardez à 20h57 en direct
euh cet appel qui a bouleversé tout le
monde aujourd'hui c'est l'appel de la
maman de Lina regardez elle était devant
les caméras regardez ma fille lina 15
ans a disparu samedi matin vers 11h20
elle a envoyé un message à son petit ami
c'est la dernière fois qu'on a eu des
contacts avec elle elle devait se rendre
à Strasbourg elle est blonde elle porte
une doudoune blanche courte une robe
grise qui arrive à mim-olet elle a des
converses
hautes blanche beige tout de su personne
susceptible d'avoir des informations je
vous remercie de contacter le numéro de
téléphone communiquer sur l'appel à
témoin je vous
remercie merci d'être avec nous merci
Zoé collègue de Lina je sais que c'est
c'est dur pour vous d'être avec nous sur
ce plateau à 20h58 euh vous l'avez vu la
veille de sa disparition vous allez nous
en parler dans un instant juste Michel
Marie pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
rejoignent cette affaire est très très
compliquée qu'est-ce qui sont qu'est-ce
qu'on sait alors ce que l'on sait c'est
que depuis samedi dans le courant de la
matinée dans le milieu de la matinée
Lina qui a 15 ans quitte son domicile
qui est une maison où elle vit avec sa
maman sur la commune de saintblaise l
roche c'est une une toute petite commune
et elle part à pied elle a très
exactement
2,m9 à faire pour rejoindre la gare de
ce petit village et elle a rendez-vous
avec son petit copain qui est à
Strasbourg et elle s'est volatilisé sur
le chemin alors on a deux
témoignages de gens qui l'ont croisé qui
décrivent sa tenue vestimentaire et elle
était effectivement sur ce trajet et à
partir de là on n plus de nouvell d'elle
on sait qu'elle a passé un dernier
message téléphonique à 11h20 et son
téléphone portable a été coupé à 11h22
elle n'est a priori pas montée dans le
train encore qu'il y a pas de vidéos
surveillance dans la gare de ce petit
village en revanche qu'on sait c'est
qu'elle n'est pas descendue du train à
Strasbourg donc on en D nuit qu'elle est
pas monté dans le
train quelles sont les pistes des des
enquêteurs aujourd'hui parce qu'on on a
vu qu'elle n'avait pas le profil d'une
fugueuse est-ce qu'il y a des pistes al
la piste la première Ière piste à
laquelle on pense c'est c'est une fugue
mais ils ont refermé très rapidement la
porte parce que elle rejoignait son
petit copain elle a pas de problème elle
VI avec elle vit avec sa maman il y a
pas d'incident particulier dans dans
l'histoire familiale elle
avait une activité scolaire et de de
d'initiation professionnelle à priori
tout se passait pour le mieux donc la
piste de la fugue a été très vite
écartée l'autre hypothèse c'est elle a
été peut-être agressée sur le chemin 2
km9 dont une grande partie en forêt
c'est pas forcément très prudent son
téléphone qui arrête d'émettre c'est
c'est inquiétant oui c'est inquiétant
parce que il y a aucune raison alors
sauf mais j'imagine pas que cette jeune
fille est pas recharger son téléphone
avant de partir en
weekend donc le téléphone devait être
chargé sil a été coupé c'est une
intervention manuelle volon
qui peut correspondre au moment de
l'agression c'est son ami qui alertaé la
famille s'inquiétant de ne pas voir
arriver tout à fait il est l il était à
Strasbourg il l'attendait il avait
l'horaire du train l'horaire auquel elle
devait arriver et quand le train s'est
vidé Lina n'était pas parmi les
voyageurs il a attendu un petit peu il a
essayé de la joindre elle ne répondait
plus au téléphone et il a donné l'alerte
en prévenant sa famille alors ce matin
il y a une deè batue qui a eu lieu pour
tenter de retrouver Lina cette battue
elle est effectuée sur les 2 km9 c'est
ça enfin surensemble du TR à partir du
moment on a de des témoignage qui la
situe plus proche de la gare que de son
domicile ça sert à rien d'aller chercher
en avant donc c'est entre le lieu précis
où on l'a vu et la gare alors il y a 35
gendarmes mobilisés ce matin pour la
battue et il y a aussi des des chiens
qui ont été mobilisés oui alors on a
pris des les fameux saintuber qu' qui
ont été utilisé dans la disparition des
mil000es à ma connaissance ça n'a pas
donner
grand-chose sachant que à partir du
moment où le vu les les effectifs
déployés et les les bénévoles qui se
sont
euh greffés au dispositif si elle avait
fait un malaise ou si elle avait été
agressée et laissée sur place on
l'aurait déjà retrouvé le chien ne
marque que pas a priori de euh ça pour
l'instant de non euh il y a on a regardé
les opérations de la carte bancaire de
de Lina également oui à priori sa carte
bancaire ne ne bouge pas ne fonctionne
pas en ni sa carte bancaire ni son
téléphone 11h22 et et on a borné le
téléphone est-ce qu'on peut savoir
tracer le parcours de Lina et voir où
voilà avoir une idée de d'où elle a été
son téléphone s'est arrêté oui tout à
fait on peut géolocaliser c'estd qu'on
on aura l'endroit précis où le téléphone
a été
comment ça prend combien de temps ça
parce que ça je pense que c'est la clé
du ça va assez vite c'est la clé du pour
moi de l'enquête aussi hein pour savoir
où qu'on aura l'endroit où où elle a
cessé de mettre ça veut pas dire pour
autant que c'est l'endroit où où elle a
été enfin si ça veut dire que c'est
l'endroit où elle a été agressée si elle
a été agressée on si elle a été agressée
euh et puis surtout ce que vont faire
les gendarmes c'est geler toute la
téléphonie toutes les bornes du coin du
secteur ce qui permettra de savoir qui
était sur place on l'a fait aussi pour
Émile qui était sur place quels étaient
les numéros de téléphone qui étaient sur
place et à partir de là c'est un travail
qui est qui est colossal enfin les
ordinateurs le font très bien ça permet
de savoir si on a un individu connu des
services de police pour des des
faits féminels alors on va revenir avec
vous sur l'enquête dans un dans une dans
une minute Michel mon est exve Zoé
collègue de Lina vous connaissez Lina
depuis de nombreuses années vous étiez
au collège ensemble sans trop vous
côtoyer mais depuis 15 jours vous étiez
devenu collègue vous travaillez ensemble
où au proxy cigriste à saintbl la roche
d'accord donc dans un
supermarché un supermarché de proximité
c'est ça oui exactement euh vous
entendiez bien ça ça va et oui oui super
bien après on a une superbe ambiance
dans cette entreprise donc il y a pas de
raison vous vous avez quel âge vous Z
j'ai 18 ans c'est ça donc elle c'était
la c la plus jeune de oui de de de
l'équipe alors euh est-ce que vous avez
senti euh Lina bizarre ou est-ce qu'elle
était sonans problème avant que vous
l'ayez vu parce que vous êtes peut-être
une des dernières personnes à à l'avoir
vu euh pas du tout bon après la première
semaine de son stage elle était très
timide d'accord je pense que c'est
normal pour toute personne qui vient
dans une entreprise où elle connaît
personne elle connaît pas la clientèle
c'est son premier stage en vente donc
elle c beaucoup de personnes plus âgées
qu'elle mais à partir de la deuxème la
deè semaine de stage elle était beaucoup
plus investie elle venait beaucoup plus
vers nous elle nous demandait de de
faire la caisse de faire plus de choses
que vous la sentiez vous la sentiez
heureuse vous sentiez super contente de
venir travailler je l' elle vous parlait
de son elle vous parlait de son copain
de qui alors oui on on parlait souvent
de son copain qu'elle était heureuse
elle me parlait pas du tout de son
copain en mal he loin de là vraiment
voilà et ça se passait bien avec sa mère
ah parfaitement elle venait même dans là
où on travaille en fait là on travaille
voilà donc la piste de la fugue est
compliquée à à croire vendredi la veille
vous avez travaillé ensemble la veille
du drame vous êtes donc une dernière une
des dernières personnes à avoir vu Lina
euh vendredi comment elle était super
contente ah vraiment super contente je
j'ai fermé le magasin avec elle à quelle
heure vous avez fermé le magasin 19h 19h
d'accord donc j'ai fermé le magasin avec
elle elle était super contente de revoir
son copain qui l'a cherché en voiture
elle vous a dit quoi elle vous a dit
ouais je vais retrouver mon copain là
c'est oui elle était super contente elle
l'avait pas vu toute la semaine parce
que du coup ben il est à Strasbourg elle
était super contente de le voir le
weekend je pense que comme toute petite
amie qui revoit son copain le
weekend vraiment aucune inquiétude il y
avait rien d'anormal rien du tout elle
vous a parlé de vous connaissiez le
trajet qu'elle allait faire oui je le
connais donc c'est moi-même des fois
quand j'étais jeune ouais c'est avec des
copines voilà c'est quoi le trajet pour
les téléspectateurs c'est quoi c'est un
trajet qui c'est un trajet bon il y a
beaucoup de forêt il y a pas de trottoir
c'est vraiment une route bon peut
circuler par les par les voitures mais
pas doucement d'accord les les voitures
ne voulaent pas vous le faisiez vous ce
tragé ou vous aviez je le faisais des
fois pour rejoindre des copines dans un
village un trag qui est voilà qui qui
est pas c'est
pas il y a pas beaucoup il y a pas
beaucoup de monde qui qui c'est surtout
des voitures mais des gens qui le font à
pied il y en a très peu ouais c'est ça
donc vous croisez très pe c'est c'est
vraiment une bordure de de route son
train éta à quelle heure euh 123 donc le
lendemain 123 d'accord donc voilà donc
elle donc c'était plutôt le dans la
matinée qu'elle elle a dû partir euh
pour rejoindre son train euh vous quand
vous avez appris la disparition
euh est-ce que vous êtes dit qu'elle
aurait pu fuguer ou pas du tout euh bah
déjà je l'ai appris par ma collègue
parce que je travaillais pas à ce
moment-là ça a été quoi votre réaction
vous avez d vous effondrer euh j'y
croyais pas
ouais vraiment je pense que mon corps il
y croyait pas parce que je voyais encore
sa tête avec moi qui fermait le magasin
qui me disait bon weekend à
lundi c'est c'est horrible c'est
horrible j'espère qu'on la retrouvver
vivante et 3 jours après sa
disparition vous croyez la piste d'une
mauvaise rencontre je
pense je pense que c'est vraiment une
personne mal inentionné qui a rencontré
son chemin on espère pas mais vous vous
avez peur pour elle mais j'ai toujours
ESP de la
retrouver c'est quoi l'ambiance
là là tout le monde est dévasté je pense
qu'ils sont
choqués bon tout le monde garde espoir
mais faut qu'on se batte tous ensembleir
ces mots qui raisonnent dans V tête que
même nous quand vous nous les dites vous
avez dit on se retrouve lundi à lundi
bon weekend c'est la c'est c'est c'est
la dernière chose qu'elle vous a
dit oui et pour préciser l'emploi du
temps donc quand vous fermez la boutique
vous voyez la voiture de son petit ami
j'ai vu qu'elle était rentrée dans sa
voiture c'est ça il vient la chercher et
ils ont prévu de passer la nuit emble et
au matin cy lui repart en voiture c'est
pour ça qu'il l'attend à Strasbourg
c'està dire qu'ils sont ensemble mais au
matin il part en voiture elle elle dit
je vais me reposer un peu et je te
rejoindrai voilà c'est ça SC donc elle a
fait les 2 km9 à pied à pied c'est ça
alors que lui était parti le matin tôt
mais elle elle a dit je vais dormir me
reposer un peu et elle part après et
Cyril comme vous le disiez c'est très
escarpé avec des bois et d'ailleurs la
la la procureure a examiné vraiment avec
les enquêteurs la tè de l'accident de
voiture possible il y a aucune marque
d'accident de voiture donc pour revenir
sur ce que disait Michel c'est une piste
qui est écartée à son tour Zoé
aujourd'hui vous avez forcément vous
avez essayé de la joindre ou pas du tout
même pas vous êtes dit de toute façon si
la personne arrive à la joindre non je
vais pas essayer moiême de ser à rien
vous êtes vous avez été voir sa maman
oui
elle vous a dit quoi ben elle a pas les
mots elle est effondrée elle est je
pense que là ici c'est c'est vraiment la
personne qui au plus bas bah bien sûr
elle perd sa fille sa seule fille on
pense tellement à elle je vous jure je
l'ai vu là c'est c'est vraiment on a
envie de la prendre dans nos bras sa
maman lui dire qu'on va on va lui
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles on est
tous bouleversés vous vous la soutenez
ah oui totalement faut faut pas la
lâcher he même avec on est tous là pour
elle voilà vraiment parce qu'il faut pas
la lâcher faut faut rester avec elle
parce que c'est vrai que pour elle vous
rendez compte c'était elle était fille
unique oui donc c'était sa fille unique
donc elle se retrouve sans sa fille
unique le soir en ne sachant pas où
elleer du jour au lendemain et en plus
quand vous ne savez pas ce qui s'est
passé c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est bien
sûr tout est horrible mais c'est encore
plus horrible on imagine on imagine
voilà on pense à elle là et on va penser
à elle tous les
jours
aujourd'hui tu as encore espoir oui j'ai
toujours espoir de la
retrouver moi je pense qu'on va la
retrouver vous dites quoi là-bas quand
vous êtes ensemble ben on parle on parle
de tout et de rien on parle du magasin
on parle de nos vies on parle vous
réussissez à à vivre une vie
normale depuis qu'elle a disparu non
c'est pas possible impossible impossible
je hier en enfin aujourd'hui hier
j'aurais encore dû travailler avec elle
je me dis mais mais en fait mais non en
fait c'est pas
possible elle est pas là vous arrivez à
dormir c'est
compliqué compliqué vous avez peur ouais
actuellement oui j'ai me j'ai peur de me
retrouver seul ah bon on s'est attaqué à
elle mais on peut s'attaquer à tout le
monde alors il y a il y a une certaine
méfiance dans le dans la dans le
quartier dans est-ce que les gens se
pensent qu'à ça se regardent se disent
ça peut je pense pas à une méfiance des
personnes qui sont làbah comme tout le
monde au battu mais je pense qu'il
protègeent un maximum leur enfant là
actuellement vous vous baladez toute
seule là en ce moment moi non non là non
je peux plus me balader toute seule
ouais quand je vois ça même ma petite
sœur qui a 2 ans de moins el non
là vous dites là personne ne se ah non
c'est pas sortez toujours à
plusieurs Michel moi je pense qu'il y a
on vit une dans une société qui est que
l'on que l'on décrit régulièrement et
souvent ici sur ce plateau
euh il faut que que que ces enfants de
de ces adolescents de de 15 ans faut
éviter qu'ils se qu'il fassent des
trajets aussi longs dans des endroits
aussi désertés aussi désertiques euh il
y a pas de vidéosurveillance sur tout le
chemin entre le domicile et la gare il y
a pas une est-ce qu'il sétait déjà passé
quelque chose dans dans dans cette cette
région dans ce quartier ou rien du tout
ma connaissance non euh et c'est sans
doute pour ça que qu'ils vont euh qu'il
le faisait Zoé aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on peut qu'est-ce qu'on peut te te te
te dire qu'est-ce qu'on peut te
souhaiter bien sûr la retrouver euh
aujourd'hui euh tu tu as envie de faire
quoi tu tu as été faire les battus tu as
été malheureusement je pouvais pas vu
que je travaille la journée d'acc
qu'est-ce que vous a dit la direction
là-bas la superérette où vous travaillez
la direction ils vous ont dit quoi ils
sont ben mes patrons ils sont de tout
cœur aussi avec elle hein bien sûr ouais
il ça ça a vraiment dévasté tout le
monde tout le monde chaque client qui
vienent parle d'elle ils l'ont vu encore
vendredi les clients tous nos habitués
d'ici ils sont dévastés c'est hor tous
les collègues parlent que de ça toute la
ville parle que de ça vos parents il
vous ont dit
quoi ils ont peur ils ont peur ils on
peur j'espè aussi la retrouver surtout
vivante c'est la seule chose que
j'espère faitme depuis samedi ça très
très très long c'est très très très long
depuis samedi plus aucune
nouvelle
lesc mich bout plus les jours passent
plus euh c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est
pas des bonnes nouvelles euh alors j'ai
envie de vous dire dans le paradoxe que
on en arrive à souhaiter qu'elle ait été
enlevée et séquestrée parce qu'au moins
on la retrouverait vivante donc vous
voyez jusqu'où on est obligé de enfin
dans les raisonnements un peu par
l'absurde
euh mais en tout cas elle est pas sur
l'axe de son domicile qui va de son
domicile à la gare donc à priori elle a
été enlevée
enlever pour quoi faire on a peut-être
une idée est-ce que son ravisseur la
conserve avec lui je on a aucune idée
pour l'instant voilà on va voir et puis
on espère on espère voilà on espère on
espère soit une voilà mais bon après
c'est vra après tout ce qu'on a entendu
en tout cas on pense très fort à sa
maman merci Zoé d'avoir été avec nous av
été formidable merci Michel à demain
merci les
chér